what gets you going right now I am
really pissed at the accounting in
Hollywood I really hate the majors they
all cheat you blind I have I have been I
have spent a lot of money with lawyers
in the last two or three years with
forensic accounting on fright night and
Child's Play and I'm now on the Queue to
be I have to there's so many people
suing the Hollywood Studios for their
accounting that you have to wait two
three four years in line
before they'll before they'll take the
case in court Jesus I mean the I look at
Child's Play and I I really forget the
numbers now but what they do is they
they charge you such a high interest
rate like 17
on whatever the unpaid amount of the
debt is so that they set it up so that
the interest rate on the deficit is
always growing larger and is larger than
the profits coming in is worked out
right so as time goes along the film
Fright Night Child's Play psycho 2 Falls
deeper into debt
now I figure I have made billions for
Hollywood
none of which not even the taste of
which they passed on I'll tell you a
very brief story about Tony Perkins
talking to Tony after uh Child's Play
after uh
psycho two have become a huge
International hit it was going for
something like a hundred million dollars
worldwide and Tony called and said uh I
have worse worse I have I have I have
points where's where's my profit
statements and they told them that he
didn't have any profits we had done that
movie for 4.9
for a little bit less than five maybe 34
million first weekend yeah and we've
done it for a little less than five
million that was the actual real cost
and Universal was saying they were still
in debt and so Tony said I'm going to
sue you and Universal and I will not say
the executive who said this
said you do that and you will never work
in Hollywood again the Tony Perkins he's
saying this and so Tony said he says
back yeah sure until the next time you
need me okay Tony directed psycho three
and he directed it because he was so
pissed off at Universal trying to short
him on his proper participation and also
when he did that and they had to pay
Tony his profits of participation I got
43 000 in deferred salary
and that's Hollywood for you if you
can't sue you're never going to see
anything on the back end that's true
pisses me off I wanted to see someone
once well but no but if you if you'd
ever had a piece of of any of those
beyond the residuals you've ever had a
piece of Superman
you'd be in this too